you were offered a million dollars to do
playboy so equal opportunity in the idea
to monetize
this moment why did you choose to say no
i realized that you know i can do so
much more and not to saying that i mean
playboy they have beautiful pictorials
they come in
it's amazing
it's going to be great no i'm sure
you're super psyched about that i'm sure
you look amazing but but they're
beautiful yeah
and i was really free back in the day
that's what i was joking about on the
nudes i was free and i you know and
actually it's a smart magazine i've been
playable it's a very their q a is
amazing it's a great institution so yeah
we can have different chapters of my
life but i totally agree with you i am a
very
chaste
proper pillars of appropriate mother now
and i'm not gonna lie to my kids i'm
gonna say that's why i am because i
tried everything and i found out that
ultimately being a good girl is where
it's at but
our history is our histories yeah and we
cannot hide behind them and i so respect
that you don't hide behind yours and
you're out there advocating for women
now i applaud you for that
[Applause]
in fact will you please tell us about
the lorena gallo foundation because i
just think you are so amazing please
tell us about that yes i created uh the
non-profit organization which is
coloring nagala foundation to basically
expand
awareness against domestic violence
sexual assault and merit of rape and i
reach out to communities and i engaged
you know the community
through activities that we do and
it's those forums are amazing to to
actually continue the education on
on the name of lorena gala foundation i
really admire you i love that you have
taken your life into a direction in
service of others
i love that you are fierce you are a
force you own your past you don't deny
it you are brave you are strong you have
a sense of humor but you have a mission
and thank you
i
i truly truly respect that
and i really thank you for this thank
you so much i appreciate it
[Applause]
you are so awesome
you can hear more from lorena and lorena
escaping bobbitt airing sunday april
24th on reels and also check out the
jordan peel documentary the four-part
series that is just phenomenal and you
can find out how to help survivors of
domestic abuse go to the drewbrymers
show.com to get lorena's actionability
and plan of how you can participate and
also may i say something else please
there's a movie about it's called
um lorena
i was lorena bobbitt by lifetime and
that just win an academy award in the
canadian uh award
of cinematography so it was basically a
recognition of the domestic violence
that is in the country as well and
around the world we will put that on our
website too thank you so much so much
going on
[Music]